your husband Dax Shepard who Indy and I
were friends with him there's a good guy
are you aware that he was on the show
recently and he casually on the air
suggested a wife swap with you and my
wife and us switching it up and he just
did it on the air and he kind of just
said it like yeah let's do it
no big deal like no big deal I this
sounds like my husband and I don't want
to hurt your feelings but that's not the
the you're not the first person he's
tried to get us to swing with really
yeah this is something he traditionally
does he's a very free spirit you know
and yes yeah he's a very selfish call
him a horndog yeah also a horn drop but
around my parents we say free spirit and
um and yeah he also you know he just
loves people he loves the human frame
and he constantly suggests at different
dinner parties that we hang out yeah it
really gets to know each other
oh really so he has said this to other
couples have you found a couple yet
that's saying well we've we've never
we're not actually swinging with anyone
but I will say we are best friends Ryan
and Amy we are so in love with them that
we've decided that we haven't
consummated and we'll never we've
decided that our couple will marry their
couple and since we got married we call
each other super spouses right and we
are the first-ever for which looks like
it's a little it's like a bit a little
bit like oh yeah the thing I'll say I
would be very interested in this except
for one thing what Dax was wearing when
he proposed this this is what Dax was
wearing on my show when he proposed this
no you can't a man a grown man can't
wear those ash costs but gosh overall
cannot wear those I'd have sex at that
do you do you oh yes you do in fact have
yeah that is your husband first of all
he can wear anything he wants yeah okay
he's that adorable and charming and he
has his own sense of style and don't you
think it's great that he doesn't just
fall in line with like I guess I'm gonna
wear a suit or you know a sweater vest
or whatever everybody else is doing I
don't know what you know I feel like an
idiot you mean if I was wearing overalls
you'd be more attractive
he's a spirited person and he likes
dressing oh he likes the rest he also
doesn't like to dress up which is where
the overalls come into play cuz like not
really he doesn't like buttons and ties
so he's gonna be casual 100% of the time
yeah he can put that outfit he's like a
fireman he can just he can get on a pole
and roll into that outfit very manly
like he does he works on all the
machines at our house anything breaks
he'll be able to fix it and though he's
got to have overalls okay all right I'll
back off
you